he said he doesn't watch stranger things
oh this guy is the worst i know
ah there you are i got something real
special for the two of you great what do
you got i'm one from today it's my
birthday i need you to throw me a party
all right make it epic surprise me are
you asking us to plan you a birthday
party yeah helen killer
pay attention did you choose us because
we're women women love planning parties
that's in the bible let's see what you
got for the big b day bash i thought you
wanted us to surprise you it's a figure
of speech detective stupid ago well i
was thinking a dj two signature
cocktails uh
passover whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa pass hors d'oeuvres was a
fundraiser for french dorks
so
no passwords i can't even answer that
all right tough guy
what do you got planned i don't know
meet at a bar and
drink there that's it
but still better than santiago's look
this is real important to me all right
my brother's hot wife is going to be
there and i haven't seen her since his
funeral
wow yeah right i mean you only get one
shot at your brother's widow all eyes
are going to be on us because freaking
frack here killed captain dozerman hey
we accidentally startled a man with a
genetic heart condition if you really
think about it his parents killed him
all right whatever look there's a horse
race going off in dubai i got serious
money on it dismissed
oh yeah we should all check out that
race
god
he is the worst captain we've ever had
he drew boobies on my bulletproof vest
he stared at me for 90 seconds while he
ate an entire peach he heard that i
speak spanish and he made me fire his
housekeeper she was polish at least he
doesn't practice his crane kicks with
you
i said not to move and this is rock
bottom oh raymond this is sad he's the
one you think of like a son right or are
you closer to santiago not that it
matters they're both equally going to
prison oh come on madeline there's no
need to gloat
though it does feel good
gloating glowed gloat i knew i never
should have trusted you yes obviously
not you're dum-dum john yeah i don't
want to remember this kind of just an
apple photo oh yeah
yeah why don't you get in there with him
oh why the heck not my kids just got me
a digital picture frank all right
everybody say nine nine nine nine um
raymond i love the scowl but could you
slump your shoulders a bit more remember
you're a man who just lost everything
and
done
we got it peralta boom are they totally
shocked is kelly like what just happened
what just happened you've been had john
you see when you handed me your unlocked
phone just now to snap that photo i
cloned it to a secure network server
when you handed once you're locked phone
oh yeah i already said that part sorry i
can't see or hear anything i'll just be
quiet from now on i might chime in with
a yeah here and there to stay in the mix
great the only way to get you to trust
me is if you thought i was portraying
halt yeah and now i have access to all
your personal correspondence all right
including all stingray authorizations
it's over kelly you're done okay
you may have won this round madeline but
you're gonna live to regret it you are
both so gonna live to regret it i agree
with what was just said so how was the
restaurant such a normal time
why are you being weird amy and i kissed
what
to keep our cover from being blown we
didn't have a choice tell me everything
charles it was just a kiss okay it was
for work it was nothing yeah who cares
about a kiss call me if you grab each
other's asses oh no no no no no no no
boyle can we please just go to dinner no
no no no no this is not how you and amy
are supposed to end you're supposed to
grow old and die holding each other as
your cruise ship slowly takes on water
what do you want me to say we tried
really hard we made rules we kept it
light and breezy light and breezy
ow bright and breezy is how you describe
a linen pants suit not a relationship
you care about we were just being
cautious cautious now
you guys started this with one foot out
the door that's what doomed you not the
universe that actually makes a lot of
sense
wow i was agreeing with you i'm sorry
i'm just so excited about all this all
right so what do i do tell me easy you
march over there you tell her how you
feel and you bring a fancy bottle of
lavender shampoo because shampooing a
woman's head is the most erotic thing
you could ever no no no shampoo that's
the worst but i am gonna go over there
i'm gonna tell her how i feel yeah you
go get her no
wait until it starts raining no that's
crazy go now okay
sorry sorry that's okay
i
was home and i really wanted to talk to
someone about us and dozerman and about
hope being gone and
then i realized that the only person i
want to talk about that stuff with is
you
so
screw just being colleagues and screw
light and breezy
right
definitely
guys we did it we really did it
oh charles is here big time
[Applause]
little rosa diaz so i hear you want me
to put in a good word for you with the
warden
yes
yes what
yes
please i love this this is so much fun
for me can i help you
i'm just trying to work up the nerve to
see her see who my female wife crystal
i was cheating on her with a waitress
from wing [ __ ] named jamie lynn one
night when i was
philandering crystal caught me kissing
jamie lynn's
heavy breasts she flew into a rage and
now she's serving five years for
aggravated assault yeah i'm sorry to
hear that yeah thanks man hey bring it
in
oh
that's the signal go
oh the phone
pretty please more
with sugar on top
more
you should have seen jamie lynn she
looked exactly like maxim hot 100
honoree jasmine sanders 35 seconds on
the download it just seems like you want
to be with jamie lynn i mean you keep
talking about her thigh gap that's my
favorite part of a woman there's nothing
more intoxicating than the clear absence
of a penis but you're right i need to
forget about crystal thanks for the
advice
i'm off to
plow my mistress more
time's up
diaz
hello
diaz
you don't even beg well have fun rotting
in prison
okay thanks for coming in
hello gina uh
what are you creeps doing made me look
away from my phone better pray i didn't
miss a text in the two seconds you
looked away
17 texts all of them important amy
suggested we'd negotiate terms so if you
agree to give my dad his blessing here's
what i'll do for you
you will never see me in my pajamas on a
family trip we will never share a bunk
bed and i won't force you to participate
in our annual themed christmas cards
this year my dad was mary and i was the
baby jesus yeah i know got one live the
nightmare ah well the list goes on i
signed it amy notarized it i'm a notary
no big deal i met the comptroller okay
you know what
this isn't about our lives getting
intertwined okay i'm actually worried
about my mom cause she's been hurt
before
this is all moving way too fast wow
gina that's really sweet the only reason
i didn't tell you guys is cause i don't
value you as people so it's like why be
honest yeah you just went back and
ruined what you said
look i know i'm a stage five player just
moan down chicks left and right but my
dad's not like that he would never hurt
your mom just talk to him you'll see
fine i'll talk to him just to ask him
some questions but go get him before i
change my mind
up i already changed my mind
all right i'm back oh oh i'm back
how's working your dead off going
horrible rosa's making me clean her
motorcycle
payback's a [ __ ]
gosh so many great payback lines wasted
on this damn this bike's muddy and this
isn't even the worst thing i had to do
gina made me call people and tell them
she was dead to see how they'd react
is she crying is she crying a little
you should be wailing you stone cold
[ __ ]
now call my other grandma
oopsie
oh my god
oh i'm sorry i lost my balance you think
i'm bothered by a little spilled
milkshake i'm a food blogger i'm stained
all over okay what is going on with you
two well you know how our parents have
been tender sexing each other oh
precisely amy ew boyle and i made a pact
to break them up and now this sticky
little gummy bear is backing out look i
know you don't want our lives
intertwined but things have changed my
father wants to marry your mom so you
choose your dad over me your co-worker
who hates you
you